all right what is going on there reject am i i'm
i'm in focus okay it goes make sure the camera's
in focus what's going on there reject nation greg
here today so uh yeah yeah this is gonna be a bit
of a weird video i i don't i'm not the kind of
guy to just like be like hey i'm gonna talk about
another youtuber right now and it's not it's not
like a call out video or something like that in
fact it's it's quite the opposite i wanted to talk
about chris stuckman in case you guys know what
chris stuckman is he's an all right youtuber he's
kind of struggling right now now hicka stuckman is
one of the biggest and probably the biggest
movie critic solo movie critic on youtube
he's one of the few youtubers that whenever he
uploads a video i at very least make a note that
i'm going to watch that video today or a minimum
tomorrow i i will watch it i i am stuck monized
to say the least and i want to talk about what
he's been doing as of late with what he's been
pursuing in filmmaking then the question was posed
to me like why do you want to do this video like
this is something i've been thinking about for
a couple weeks like why do you want to do this
you know like why do you really give a [ __ ]
about what chris stuckman's doing you know why
do you what do you care about this then i thought
about it and i realized why what his journey is is
something that's very personal for me so in this
video i'm going to share something that i have not
talked publicly about i feel like it's important
for me to express this personal story because that
would explain why i'm even here trying to show
support for chris stuckman right now in case
you guys don't know most of you probably already
watched chris stuckman but in case you don't know
um about eight months ago there was this big
announcement and deadline about how chris
stuckman is writing and directing his own feature
film and it was a big day it was a big day and it
was really exciting being especially for someone
like me who already looks up to chris suckman to
be able to do a feature film a little bit jealous
but mainly proud of the guy and then a couple
months ago he did a video where he was expressing
that there was a lot of delays that happened with
this movie one of the catalyst moments of it
had to do around the time of the whole ayatse
strike situation and then eventually led to
him realizing that you know they'd be able to
probably cut corners with their filmmaking that
he could probably make an okay movie it more than
likely would not be able to become the movie that
he sought to make that he envisions because of the
funding they currently had at the time so what
he ended up doing was launching this kickstarter
for his movie and oh boy uh in like 24 hours it
made over 250 000 from my understanding it's b
it's on track to become the highest grossing
horror movie on kickstarter and believe me
there's a lot of them and it's currently the
highest trending campaign in the horror movie
category which is a big deal because there's
a there's a lot of those so full disclosure
couple things i have pledged to as kickstarter
secondly i want to make this really clear
no one reached out to me like hey greg saw your
channel any chance you want to like promote this
that's not what happened at all in fact i am the
one who reached out to chris duckman myself you
know real quick i'm sure i could find a clip of
chris stuckman describing what this movie is so
let me roll like some footage of chris explain
what this movie is shelby oaks is a horror film
about missing paranormal investigators who were
very active in the youtube sphere around the mid
2000s when the platform first launched the film
explores the dark legacy that that group uncovered
and how it has ever reaching effects even 12
years into the future as the lead paranormal
investigator riley is desperately searched for by
her older sister mia and as mia begins to uncover
disturbing leads related to the disappearance of
the paranormal paranoids she discovers evidence
of a hidden supernatural evil dating all the
way back to her and riley's childhood i really
support this project i really believe in him as a
filmmaker i mean you watch his movie reviews this
guy clearly knows what he's talking about and i
think it's just a fun journey to see if this guy
can put his money where his mouth is so if you're
able to support the shelby oaks kickstarter please
there's a link in the description box and pin
comment i'm going to make sure to do that unless
of course you're thinking about pledging to our
patreon and then then pledge for our patreon
share support for shelby oaks now really
the the only extra touch i can give to this
is why what he's doing means so much to me in my
personal life some of you guys might know this
that my main passion is actually in screenwriting
that's right the jackass is always talking about
marvel dc and star wars actually has a big passion
for psychological supernatural horror-driven
movies like chris duckman's movie like that genre
i'm like that's that's mainly what i write in cool
yeah it's like it goes without saying that for
someone who talks about movies for a living and
then is able to go on to making his own that alone
is inspiring but there's a little bit more to the
story than that so in the past few years there's
been a couple of projects one project that was
public about on this channel which i do got to
acknowledge and uh yeah some embarrassment that
just like rose up out of me uh out of that just
remembering and then there's another project that
i've been waiting for like my baller chris
stuckman move like for for this movie to get
announced and then when you're reading through
the paragraphs you're like what is that gregor's
name like i wanted that situation to happen but
uh yeah that's i i have to talk about this so
the first thing there's a movie that was in
development that we were working on that i
co-wrote and uh we had a lot of like pretty big
people attached to it it just really seemed like
it was gonna be made and then the team behind it
was like yeah you should make an announcement on
your channel and even at the time i was like yeah
are we jumping the shark a little bit here you
know shouldn't we wait till we're like actually
really filming we went ahead and did it and uh
yeah and then and it looked like it was about
to happen but but then didn't the scheduling
conflicts occur because everyone's working all the
time on their other movies and stuff like they are
i'm not even there working on their movies
and stuff and admittedly it was pretty
like it was embarrassing to like make a big
announcement feel like guys i got something
special to share with you and now it's not
happening but it's not dead i can't say it's
dead because it's really just one of those things
that's on pause right now and this other project
was something that i did before that see like
uh i don't really want to give any names here a
couple years ago there's a gentleman i met who is
a quite revered in the industry in the profession
that he has like he's really well regarded i got
to meeting him one night and uh at a friend's
birthday party i believe and we just talked about
movies all day we really just you know we we
click man you feel the sparks man he's a great guy
he's like a great guy then a couple days later he
he hit me up and he's like hey i actually have
this movie idea if i've had it for a while and
i got all these this concept art to develop word
like do you want to write it and i was like yeah
let me let me have a shot at writing this because
that's always been my dream is to write through
the year and a half frost it was like a long
process of writing and rewriting eventually got it
to a studio i won't say which one it's not one of
the major ones like warner brothers or something
but it's a studio that more than likely you have
heard i've got to the studio studio now owns it i
signed the contracts on the deal a deal done on my
end i'm square i'm good to go and that was about
four years ago i want to say it was a while ago
hey i was proud of that because not one bit of
that process even from meeting that gentleman
he had never seen the real rejects so i i was
actually proud of the fact that i didn't have to
use any of like hey we got a following on youtube
in order to get it fine like i don't think there's
anything wrong with that personally i think that's
like use whatever tools you have at your disposal
i 100 believe in that i was just kind of like
giddy about like i didn't have to do that and the
script got to where it was and i'm such a i'm so
such an amateur at this i'm so like intermediate
at this and this is a big part of why i think
chris stuckman's kickstarter is so rewarding i
don't understand so much with the ins and outs
of the business side of things you know like they
literally can do whatever they want with it and my
name will just be attached like that happens all
the time and honestly like 99 of the time a lot
of people don't realize this no vast majority
of screenplays just sit on shelves they don't
actually get made that's within like these studios
whether they'd be smaller big ones most don't get
made but like every few months i will get some
like random update which i'm which i'm grateful
for and and they're usually like really cool
updates they're it's their updates that get me
excited they're updates that make me feel like oh
my god this is actually going to get made because
at the end of the day that this that feeling
that chris stuckman expressed in his video
knowing the optics surrounding him of youtuber
turned filmmaker now going to make his own movie
there's going to just be a whole like much more
critical eyes on him to see like hey he's been
criticizing [ __ ] for a while can you actually
get this done and for me i'm like ah no one's
really gonna take me seriously unless there's
something actually made and if it's made it has
to be good for somebody like somebody has
to actually get made and for the past like
a few years i get some random update every few
months about like hey it looks like it's actually
getting a shot we're going to start gearing up in
december we're going to start gearing up february
there's always something like we're going to start
gearing up to do this we're going to start gearing
up to do this we're going to start gearing up
to do this and it's in the hands of so many
other people and other people you got to answer
to and and i like there's just so much i don't
personally quite get about it especially when
working with these studios like there's so much
i don't understand and then my favorite updates
honestly if there's one that i always find really
positive the lead character in that project which
i really do believe in by the way i think it's
i like the script a lot and i think it would be
a really cool movie but the whole thing is just
out of my hands the main character is a lady and
and there's so many actresses actresses i just
love who will read it and then they'll want
to do it they'll want to do it but then
all the kind of things chris stuckman talked about
and for funding issues shooting schedule conflicts
because like everyone is already involved they're
working on other things and then like we have one
actress who i was like oh man that would be
nuts if we got her and she wanted to do it but
there was a certain time frame that she wanted to
film at where the director he couldn't make that
work because he was working on something else at
the time a whole bunch of different variations of
the story have happened so many times you know
and also it was like pretty demotivating for a
while you know because at the end of the
day i think most of us don't want to just
write like a lot of us a lot of people who write
love to love to write but at the end of the day
it's like you want one of these to get actually
made right what he's done while he's working
with producers obviously you have to there's
no way he is taking this into his own hands
as much as possible it's not dealing with a lot
of the things with a lot of the feedback i'd say
i'm being kind of careful of my words here a lot
of the feedback that i've heard of like maybe we
gotta change this changes cut this work around
this and it's like man that's really it's really
harming the story like a lot of things i hear i'm
like that's really harming this and the stuff i'm
writing is not like crazy budget [ __ ] you know
it's around the ballpark of what chris stuckman's
actually aiming for so i get it like i i i i
really sympathize with him in this situation the
fact that he's doing it this way taking this leap
something that was posed to us for the project
that i announced here when that got put to a halt
they were like do you want to do a i was like nah
i don't i don't really want to do a kickstarter
i just i had a lack of confidence at the time
so i'm here to announce we are launching
our kickstarter now i'm not gonna do that
the fact that he likes to push past that fear
decided to launch it and now it's seeing so
much success it's like almost at a half a million
dollars this kickstarter already it's going till
the end of the month i want to say why i
believe even more in this project now than
before is because he already was aware of the
pressure of having to basically prove himself
right he was already aware of that now when you're
receiving you know financial support from your own
audience like these are the people you you wanted
to then to pay to see your movie never seen a
financial support to get it made he's gonna make
it better than ever like let me put it to you like
this if he had just only gotten like the the money
he needed to really fulfill the vision he had
from a studio directly instead of having to start
a kickstarter let's say he just got that money i
think he'd make a good movie i don't feel like
it'd be as good as the one he's gonna make now
because when you have your audience supporting
you like that there's something in you that
has to click and then from the brief times i've
talked with this man who's a very very kind person
very kind very sincere as about as sincere as
you'd expect him to be especially watch his videos
you know that he's gonna take this more serious
than ever and he's gonna try to make this even
better than before because of the fact that he
knows his audience is throwing down money to help
support his movie and his kickstarter he's aiming
to show you the ins and outs the nitty-gritty
of the development process just trying to get one
of these goddamn things made and i love that he's
willing to share that because there's so much of
it that i could have used and the fact that he's
doing this as independently as possible with the
team that he obviously trusts with the support
of you guys he's making this like a collective
community experience i think it's a great path
for a lot of us to go down because 99 of the
i live in los angeles all right so throw a
rock out the window you're you're bound to hit a
screenwriter an actor you know like you're gonna
find someone in this building alone i know there's
like other people here who are also in the field
hey guys i wish i thought of this like when i
was filming it but i'm like i'm trimming this
down right now and i'm realizing that he's getting
this all done while staying in his own hometown
which is also incredibly inspiring i can't
tell you the amount of people i've met
that have moved out here to try to make it happen
and then they get discouraged and move back home
and just don't follow their dreams anymore because
they feel like they didn't make it out in la and
he's proving that you can do this while being in
your own hometown building a community out there
that is that is seriously like mesmerizing
to me i'm getting nipple chills just talking
about it right now what he's doing in the
indie filmmaking route i think is very
inspiring and is conquering obstacles that a lot
of us can learn from and so yeah i just want to
throw my support for him publicly and i wanted to
encourage you guys to support the project as well
and yeah and uh if any of my things ever get shot
we'll let you know you know but thank you guys for
being here i really appreciate you like kicking
it with me for now i'll talk to you guys soon
you